Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therin from CBS News. In Dallas, Texas, three shots were fired at President Kennedy's motorcade in downtown Dallas. The first reports say President Kennedy has been seriously wounded by this shooting. More details just arrived. These details about the same as previously. President Kennedy shot today, just as his motorcade left downtown Dallas.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。这是来自哥伦比亚广播公司（CBS）新闻的消息。在德克萨斯州达拉斯市，肯尼迪总统的车队在达拉斯市中心遭到三枪射击。初步报道称，肯尼迪总统在这次枪击事件中受重伤。更多细节刚刚传来。这些细节与之前报道的基本一致。肯尼迪总统今天在车队离开达拉斯市中心时遭到枪击。
Mrs. Kennedy jumped up and grabbed Mr. Kennedy. She called, oh no. The motorcade sped on. United Press International reports that the wounds perhaps could be fatal. So that was CBS News interrupting Dominic, I think, a soap opera, wasn't it? Yeah. With the first news of the assassination of President John F. Kennedy, JFK, on the 22nd of November, 1963.
肯尼迪夫人跳起来抓住了肯尼迪先生。她喊道，哦，不。车队加速驶离。合众国际社报道称，伤势可能致命。所以那是哥伦比亚广播公司新闻中断了多米尼克，我想，那是一部肥皂剧，对吧？是的。那是1963年11月22日约翰·F·肯尼迪总统（JFK）遇刺的第一条新闻。
Yes, 60 years, Tom, it'll be since the Kennedy assassination. And I suppose you could say it's the first great televised historical moment, isn't it? One of the first moments for which we have television pictures, but that was also a television event. So the images of people kind of gathering outside TV stores, washing through the windows in absolute shock. And you starting with that reading, that beautifully done reading, I have to say, Tom. Thank you very much. Thank you. The right kind of mournful, serious tone that people expect from the rest is history. And lots of our American listeners will be very familiar with that. They'll have seen that clip a thousand times in documentaries. I mean, I would say the Kennedy
是的，汤姆，肯尼迪遇刺已经60年了。我想你可以说这是第一个伟大的电视历史时刻，不是吗？这是我们拥有电视画面的最早时刻之一，但那也是一个电视事件。所以人们聚集在电视商店外，透过窗户观看，感到极度震惊的画面。而你以那段朗读开始，我必须说，汤姆，做得非常漂亮。非常感谢。谢谢。这正是人们对《历史的余味》所期待的那种哀伤、严肃的基调。我们许多美国听众会非常熟悉这一点。他们在纪录片中看过那段片段一千次了。我的意思是，我会说肯尼迪
assassination is one of the three most famous assassinations in history, alongside Julius Caesar and Abraham Lincoln. Where's Franz Ferdinand? Shocking. No, not as famous. Not as famous. The thing about the Kennedy assassination, unlike those previous two, is that there is an incredible sense of mystery, paranoia, and suspicion of conspiracy around it. I mean, we did, what, two episodes on the assassination of Julius Caesar, but no one was really in any doubt as to who did it and why and we talked about lincoln's assassination in the episodes we did on the american civil war again there's not really much doubt who did it and why yeah but with this
遇刺案是历史上最著名的三起暗杀事件之一，与尤利乌斯·凯撒和亚伯拉罕·林肯并列。弗朗茨·斐迪南去哪了？令人震惊。不，没那么出名。没那么出名。关于肯尼迪遇刺案，与前两起不同的是，它周围有一种令人难以置信的神秘感、偏执和阴谋论的怀疑。我的意思是，我们做了，什么，两集关于尤利乌斯·凯撒遇刺的节目，但没有人真正怀疑是谁干的以及为什么，我们在关于美国内战的剧集中谈到了林肯的遇刺，同样，对于是谁干的以及为什么，并没有太多的怀疑，是的，但对于这个
there is controversy isn't there yes and i'm really looking forward to these episodes because the 60s and 70s in amer America is your kind of academic specialization. So I know that you focused on Kennedy's rival in the election, presidential election that brought Kennedy to power, Richard Nixon. But presumably you must have studied and written about and lectured on Kennedy as well. Do you know what, Tom? This is a funny admission. It was seeing Oliver Stone's film, JFK, a film that actually now I hold in quite low regard historically. It was seeing that that made me fall in love with American history. I vividly remember going to see it. I think it was probably in 1991, 2, when I was a teenager and being completely fascinated by the way in which
有争议，不是吗？是的，我真的很期待这些剧集，因为美国的60年代和70年代是你的学术专长。所以我知道你专注于肯尼迪在选举中的竞争对手，即让肯尼迪上台的那次总统选举中的理查德·尼克松。但想必你也一定研究过、写过并讲授过肯尼迪。你知道吗，汤姆？这是一个有趣的承认。是看了奥利弗·斯通的电影《刺杀肯尼迪》（JFK），一部我现在在历史上评价相当低的电影。是看了那部电影让我爱上了美国历史。我清楚地记得去看它。我想那可能是在1991年或92年，当时我还是个青少年，完全被那种方式所吸引
his assassination conspiracy theories opened the door into all these different subjects. So Vietnam, civil rights, the military industrial complex, the Cold War, and so on. The first extended bit of historical writing I ever did, which was my sixth form history project, we had to do like an extended essay, was about the domestic policies of President Kennedy. It turned out to be quite a boring piece of work. So let's hope the podcasts turn out to be more exciting. Well, I guess the justification for doing a big series on the Kennedy assassination is that the paranoid style in American politics.
他的暗杀阴谋论打开了通往所有这些不同主题的大门。比如越南、民权、军工复合体、冷战等等。我写过的第一篇长篇历史文章，也就是我的高中历史项目，我们必须写一篇长篇论文，是关于肯尼迪总统的国内政策。结果那是一篇相当无聊的作品。所以希望播客会变得更令人兴奋。好吧，我想做关于肯尼迪遇刺的大型系列的理由是美国政治中的偏执风格。
Yes. Richard Hofstadter, which he wrote the year after the assassination. Yeah. But that paranoid style is in itself a theme. Absolutely, it is. America has never really, I mean, it's never really banished in itself a theme. Absolutely, it is. That America has never really, I mean, it's never really banished, has it? No, absolutely it is. I think what gives the Kennedy story such fascination is just the combination of that paranoia and the idea that if you can solve the mystery of
是的。理查德·霍夫施塔特（Richard Hofstadter），他在暗杀事件发生后一年写的。是的。但那种偏执风格本身就是一个主题。绝对是。美国从来没有真正，我的意思是，它从来没有真正消除过，本身就是一个主题。绝对是。美国从来没有真正，我的意思是，它从来没有真正消除过，对吧？不，绝对是。我认为让肯尼迪的故事如此引人入胜的是那种偏执与这样一种想法的结合：如果你能解开
Kennedy assassination, if indeed there is a mystery, then that will unlock the key to understanding American power and politics and all American history. So there's that combined with the allure of Kennedy himself. So in other words, if it had been Nixon who had won that election in 1960 and then been assassinated, I don't think there would be quite the same public fixation. I mean, of course, it would still be very interesting, but it's the fact that Kennedy was so glamorous that he had a, shall we say, very colourful love life, the nature of his family. And the bit in the news report, you know, Mrs. Kennedy jumped up and grabbed Mr. Kennedy, the tragedy of that. Yes.
肯尼迪遇刺之谜，如果确实存在一个谜团的话，那么这将是理解美国权力和政治以及整个美国历史的关键。所以这与肯尼迪本人的魅力结合在一起。换句话说，如果1960年赢得那场选举并被暗杀的是尼克松，我不认为会有同样的公众关注。我的意思是，当然，它仍然会非常有趣，但事实是肯尼迪如此迷人，他有一个，我们称之为，非常丰富多彩的爱情生活，他家庭的本质。还有新闻报道中的那一段，你知道，肯尼迪夫人跳起来抓住了肯尼迪先生，那场悲剧。是的。
The personal drama of it. Exactly. Camelot, you know, this is the Mort Dartha of American politics. Yeah, yeah. I mean, it's a tremendous story. And I agree, I always found Kennedy a very politically appealing figure. Right. He's a very charismatic figure.
个人的戏剧性。正是如此。卡米洛特（Camelot），你知道，这是美国政治的《亚瑟王之死》（Le Morte d'Arthur）。是的，是的。我的意思是，这是一个了不起的故事。我同意，我一直觉得肯尼迪是一个非常有政治吸引力的人物。对。他是一个非常有魅力的人物。
I'm looking forward to you telling me that he's not at all. No, because the funny thing about Kennedy, Tom, is that when I started out as a sort of, you know, as a graduate student and then as a young academic, Kennedy was held, I would say, by and large, in quite low regard by historians because there had been a backlash against the Camelot myth. So there were a whole load of monographs saying, oh, actually Kennedy, very passive on civil rights. The sense of Kennedy's family was that they were semi-criminal or whatever. And there was also a sort of sense, I think, in academia that as a subject, Kennedy was vulgar because he was too popular, because he was too sensational. So I'm guessing the whole, I mean, I'm giving away a spoiler here for people who haven't seen the Kevin Costner, JFK film, the Oliver Stone film. But the whole point of that is that he's
我很期待你告诉我他一点也不。不，因为关于肯尼迪有趣的事情是，汤姆，当我刚开始作为一名，你知道，研究生，然后作为一名年轻学者时，肯尼迪被历史学家普遍认为评价相当低，因为当时对卡米洛特神话有强烈的反弹。所以有大量的专著说，哦，实际上肯尼迪在民权问题上非常被动。肯尼迪家庭的感觉是他们是半犯罪的等等。而且我认为在学术界也有一种感觉，即作为一个主题，肯尼迪是庸俗的，因为他太受欢迎了，因为他太耸人听闻了。所以我猜整个，我的意思是，我在这里为那些没看过凯文·科斯特纳的《刺杀肯尼迪》电影、奥利弗·斯通电影的人剧透了。但那部电影的全部意义在于他
basically assassinated to stop him from stopping the Vietnam War. Yes. Which I'm guessing is perhaps not entirely plausible. No, because that is a really live historiographical argument. What would Kennedy have done in Vietnam if he had not died? So the interesting thing with the mystery element to it is when you're trying to solve any murder mystery, so it be an Agatha Christie or a Dorothy L. Sayers murder or whatever,
基本上被暗杀是为了阻止他停止越南战争。是的。我猜这可能并不完全可信。不，因为那是一个非常活跃的史学争论。如果肯尼迪没有死，他在越南会做什么？所以神秘元素有趣的地方在于，当你试图解决任何谋杀之谜时，无论是阿加莎·克里斯蒂还是多萝西·L·塞耶斯的谋杀案，
the personality and the behavior of the victim are crucially important. The murderee, as Martin Amis would call it. Yeah, the murder-ee. The nature of the person who is murdered helps you to understand why he's murdered and who did it. So in episode one, should we have a look at Kennedy's character, his origins, the things that shaped him? Sure, because I think understanding the victim in this story will help us to solve the case, Tom. Fantastic.
受害者的个性和行为至关重要。马丁·艾米斯（Martin Amis）称之为“被谋杀者”（murderee）。是的，被谋杀者。被谋杀者的本质有助于你理解他为什么被谋杀以及是谁干的。所以在第一集中，我们应该看看肯尼迪的性格、他的出身、塑造他的事物吗？当然，因为我认为理解这个故事中的受害者将帮助我们破案，汤姆。太棒了。
Because it will help us to eliminate other possibilities and to get to the truth. So he is of Irish stock and America's first Catholic president. Those are the two things that I always knew about his upbringing. Yes, Tom, he is very Irish. His great-great-grandfather, Patrick Kennedy, had moved from Ireland in the late 1840s to escape the famine. Then there's another Patrick. Then there is Joe, Joseph Kennedy. Now he is Kennedy's father, and he is a titanic figure of Kennedy's life is also a book about his father because his father is such a towering influence. Joe Kennedy, who becomes a stockbroker and so on and a kind of political figure, Joe Kennedy had married the daughter of the mayor of Boston, a guy called Honey Fitz. And the daughter was called Rose Fitzgerald. And she is Jack Kennedy's mother. So they get married. Can I give you an amazing fact about John Fitzgerald?
因为这将帮助我们排除其他可能性并找到真相。所以他是爱尔兰血统，也是美国第一位天主教总统。这是我一直以来对他成长经历了解的两件事。是的，汤姆，他非常爱尔兰。他的曾曾祖父帕特里克·肯尼迪在19世纪40年代末从爱尔兰搬来以逃避饥荒。然后是另一个帕特里克。然后是乔，约瑟夫·肯尼迪。现在他是肯尼迪的父亲，他是肯尼迪生命中一个泰坦式的人物，这也是一本关于他父亲的书，因为他父亲是一个如此高耸的影响力。乔·肯尼迪，他成为了一名股票经纪人等等，也是一个政治人物，乔·肯尼迪娶了波士顿市长的女儿，一个叫“蜂蜜”菲茨（Honey Fitz）的人。女儿叫罗斯·菲茨杰拉德。她是杰克·肯尼迪的母亲。所以他们结婚了。我能告诉你一个关于约翰·菲茨杰拉德的惊人事实吗？
Honey Fitz. I know you love an amazing fact. So he was mayor of Boston, wasn't he? He was, yes. And he was the person who set up the first ever public Christmas tree in America in 1912. Really? And it was half an hour before one was switched on in Madison Square Park in New York. That's an absolutely tremendous fact, Tom.
“蜂蜜”菲茨。我知道你喜欢惊人的事实。所以他是波士顿市长，对吧？他是，是的。他是在1912年在美国设立第一棵公共圣诞树的人。真的吗？而且是在纽约麦迪逊广场公园的一棵树被点亮前半小时。那绝对是一个了不起的事实，汤姆。
I went down a wormhole last night. You clearly did. And I thought, that's an interesting fact. You clearly did. Maybe we should do a podcast about the history of Christmas trees instead. Well, it's coming, isn't it? Yes, exactly. So you have Joe Kennedy and Rose Fitzgerald. They have two sons initially. So they have Joe Jr., who was born, I think, 1915. And they have Jack, who was born in 1917. And Jack is born in a place called Brookline, which is a kind of middle-class affluent suburb of Boston. So they are moving rapidly up through the sort of social echelons of Boston. So this rapidly moving up through social echelons, they are Catholic. Boston famously
我昨晚钻进了一个兔子洞。你显然钻了。我想，那是一个有趣的事实。你显然钻了。也许我们应该做一个关于圣诞树历史的播客。好吧，它要来了，不是吗？是的，正是如此。所以你有乔·肯尼迪和罗斯·菲茨杰拉德。他们最初有两个儿子。所以他们有小乔，我想是1915年出生的。他们有杰克，1917年出生的。杰克出生在一个叫布鲁克莱恩（Brookline）的地方，那是波士顿的一种中产阶级富裕郊区。所以他们正在迅速地在波士顿的社会阶层中向上移动。所以这种在社会阶层中迅速向上移动，他们是天主教徒。波士顿著名地
is founded as a Protestant city. So is there prejudice among the Boston Brahmins against Catholics? There undoubtedly is. So the funny thing with Jack Kennedy, actually, he has a great lesson in the importance of nuance and understanding class. And people always think that the British are peculiarly obsessed with this, but you see this brilliantly in Boston. So the Kennedys are a rich family. His father is very successful on Wall Street, has two Rolls Royces, has enough money to buy a summer home on Cape Cod at Hyannisport, the kind of Kennedy compound, as it ends up being called. He's a billionaire, I think, in today's money, Tom.
被建立为一个新教城市。那么波士顿婆罗门（Boston Brahmins）对天主教徒有偏见吗？毫无疑问是有。所以关于杰克·肯尼迪有趣的事情是，实际上，他在理解细微差别和阶级重要性方面有一个很好的教训。人们总是认为英国人对此特别痴迷，但你在波士顿能精彩地看到这一点。所以肯尼迪家族是一个富裕的家庭。他的父亲在华尔街非常成功，有两辆劳斯莱斯，有足够的钱在科德角的海恩尼斯港买一个避暑别墅，也就是后来被称为肯尼迪大院的地方。我想他以今天的货币计算是亿万富翁，汤姆。
Because he wanted to make 2 million by the time he was 35. 35, exactly. Yes, he did indeed. He had gone to Harvard though, Joseph Kennedy, and not been allowed in to the big clubs on campus. He hadn't been admitted to the Protestant boarding school dominated social clubs that the Boston Brahmin boys went to. Later on, he joins some country clubs, but he's not invited to all of them when he's successful. And Joe Kennedy, who is a very prickly and proud man, really feels that. He feels a tremendous sense of being an outsider, even though he's extremely rich, very well integrated in society. The fact that he's a Catholic and they are Catholics and they are Irish and they're shut out,
因为他想在35岁时赚到200万。35岁，正是。是的，他确实做到了。不过约瑟夫·肯尼迪确实上了哈佛，但没有被允许进入校园里的大俱乐部。他没有被录取到波士顿婆罗门男孩去的新教寄宿学校主导的社交俱乐部。后来，他加入了一些乡村俱乐部，但他成功时并没有被邀请参加所有这些俱乐部。而乔·肯尼迪，一个非常易怒且骄傲的人，真的感觉到了这一点。他有一种巨大的局外人感，尽管他非常富有，在社会中融合得很好。他是一个天主教徒，他们是天主教徒，他们是爱尔兰人，他们被拒之门外，
that really eats away at him. I don't think it ever ate away at Jack Kennedy, actually. In fact, Jack Kennedy was very good at being accepted by these things despite being a Catholic. But for the family at large, it creates this sense of being it's sort of us against the world, Team Kennedy, all of this kind of thing. Go on, Tom. Because Honey Fitz, the grandfather of JFK, after whom jfk is named john fitzgerald yes the mayor with his christmas tree he gets that nickname honey doesn't he because he's incredibly charming yeah people love him yeah and joe kennedy seems not to have had that not he wouldn't have done i mean he's as you said very prickly man but jfk really does have that he seems to have inherited
这真的让他很痛苦。我不认为这真的让杰克·肯尼迪感到痛苦。事实上，杰克·肯尼迪尽管是天主教徒，却非常擅长被这些东西所接受。但对于整个家庭来说，这创造了一种“我们对抗世界”的感觉，肯尼迪团队，所有这类事情。继续，汤姆。因为“蜂蜜”菲茨，JFK的祖父，JFK以他命名约翰·菲茨杰拉德，是的，那个有圣诞树的市长，他得到了那个绰号“蜂蜜”，不是吗？因为他非常有魅力，是的，人们爱他，是的，而乔·肯尼迪似乎没有那种，不，他不会有的，我的意思是，正如你所说，他是一个非常易怒的人，但JFK确实有那种，他似乎继承了
this charm via his mother from his grandfather. He definitely did. When he was a boy, people used to say he really takes after Honey Fitz. Everybody loves him. He's very funny. He's very charming. So in personality, he's much closer to Honey Fitz. His father's influence, though, is really important. One thing about his father, by the way, everybody thinks that Joe Kennedy was crooked.
这种魅力是通过他的母亲从他的祖父那里继承来的。他绝对继承了。当他还是个男孩时，人们常说他真的很像“蜂蜜”菲茨。每个人都爱他。他非常有趣。他非常有魅力。所以在个性上，他更接近“蜂蜜”菲茨。不过，他父亲的影响确实很重要。顺便说一句，关于他父亲的一件事，每个人都认为乔·肯尼迪是腐败的。
It's one of the few things that most people know about Joe Kennedy. That he was a bootlegger in Prohibition. Yeah, but he actually wasn't, Tom. Wasn't he? There Joe Kennedy. That he was a bootlegger in Prohibition. Yeah, but he actually wasn't, Tom. Wasn't he? There's no evidence that he was a bootlegger at all. So there's a historian called David Nassau who's really gone into this. A lot of that is probably prejudice against a prickly, proud Irish Catholic businessman. And people say, oh, he's crooked.
这是大多数人了解乔·肯尼迪的少数几件事之一。他在禁酒令期间是个私酒贩子。是的，但他实际上不是，汤姆。不是吗？那里乔·肯尼迪。他在禁酒令期间是个私酒贩子。是的，但他实际上不是，汤姆。不是吗？没有证据表明他是个私酒贩子。所以有一位叫大卫·纳索（David Nassau）的历史学家真正深入研究了这一点。很多那可能是对一个易怒、骄傲的爱尔兰天主教商人的偏见。人们说，哦，他是腐败的。
He's probably in league with the mafia and all this stuff. Now, he was very ruthless. But as Fred Logerville writes in his biography, Joe Kennedy always moved very cautiously in his business affairs, always placing a premium on achieving and maintaining the appearances of respectability. He knew that as an Irish Catholic, he was vulnerable, that his opponents would seize on any mistake to say, so actually, the evidence of bootlegging is minimal. The truth of the matter is he's a rapacious businessman who makes a lot of enemies and they say he's crooked,
他可能与黑手党勾结，所有这些东西。现在，他非常无情。但正如弗雷德·洛格瓦尔（Fred Logevall）在他的传记中所写，乔·肯尼迪在商业事务中总是非常谨慎，总是把实现和保持体面的外表放在首位。他知道作为一个爱尔兰天主教徒，他是脆弱的，他的对手会抓住任何错误说，所以实际上，私酒贩子的证据是极少的。事实是，他是一个贪婪的商人，制造了很多敌人，他们说他是腐败的，
but he's probably not really crooked. He's also a very competitive dad, isn't he? So he's endlessly telling his children that they have to be the best. If he does sport with them or board games, he's always out to beat them as hard as he possibly can. He does things like he will throw them into the seat on one of the yachts to get them to swim. Well, you know, I mean, that's what parenting is all about, a single swim. But he kind of passes that on, doesn't he? That kind of will to win to JFK, but also to JFK's elder brother, Joe Jr., who is absolutely the alpha male. He is. So Joe Jr. is the apple of his father's eye.
但他可能并不是真的腐败。他也是一个非常有竞争力的父亲，不是吗？所以他不断地告诉他的孩子们他们必须是最好的。如果他和他们一起做运动或玩棋盘游戏，他总是想尽一切办法打败他们。他会做一些事情，比如把他们扔进游艇的座位里让他们游泳。好吧，你知道，我的意思是，这就是为人父母的全部意义，一次游泳。但他确实把那种东西传下去了，不是吗？那种获胜的意志传给了JFK，也传给了JFK的哥哥小乔，他绝对是阿尔法男性。他是。所以小乔是他父亲眼中的苹果。
Joe Jr. is slavishly obedient to his father, follows his father's opinions in all things, very serious, kind of rough, slightly kind of clunking kind of character, I would say, Joe Jr. Jack is different. He should be called Biff. Yes, he absolutely should be. He should be a high school star. Yeah, exactly.
小乔对他父亲唯命是从，在所有事情上都遵循他父亲的意见，非常严肃，有点粗鲁，有点笨拙的角色，我会说，小乔。杰克则不同。他应该叫比夫（Biff）。是的，他绝对应该。他应该是一个高中明星。是的，正是如此。
He's a person who always comes out ultimately badly from high school comedies. Yes. But Jack is quite different. So Jack is a very sickly boy. He got scarlet fever when he was two, and that basically set the tone for everything that was to follow.
他是一个在高中喜剧中最终总是表现得很糟糕的人。是的。但杰克完全不同。所以杰克是一个非常多病的男孩。他两岁时得了猩红热，这基本上为后来的一切定下了基调。
He's just endlessly ill, but also he clearly has a congenital spinal issue that goes undiagnosed for a very long time. So he is a very poorly little boy. He's also very bright. People talk about him loving reading. They're not a great family of readers, the Kennedys, but he is. So he loves reading Walter Scott.
他只是不断地生病，而且他显然有一个先天性的脊柱问题，很长一段时间都没有被诊断出来。所以他是一个非常可怜的小男孩。他也非常聪明。人们谈论他热爱阅读。肯尼迪一家不是一个伟大的阅读家庭，但他确实是。所以他喜欢读沃尔特·斯科特。
And he loves the Arabian Nights, which we've recently been talking about. Exactly, Tom. He loves adventure stories and romantic stories. He clearly is somebody with a kind of lively, swashbuckling imagination. Now, the thing is, their family dynamic is one that would actually crush a sort of lesser person because you talk about the winning thing. I mean, even in the summer, Rose Fitzgerald Kennedy, so that's the mother. She would post a schedule for events every evening for the following day. So it'd be like tennis, 10 o'clock, golf,
他喜欢《一千零一夜》，我们最近一直在谈论它。正是如此，汤姆。他喜欢冒险故事和浪漫故事。他显然是一个有着活泼、冒险想象力的人。现在，问题是，他们的家庭动态实际上会压垮一个某种程度上较弱的人，因为你谈论获胜的事情。我的意思是，即使在夏天，罗斯·菲茨杰拉德·肯尼迪，也就是母亲。她会为第二天晚上的活动张贴时间表。所以就像网球，10点，高尔夫，
a conversation about politics at 11.30, all this kind of thing, which visitors to the house found generally terrifying and absolutely chilling. Yes, clarinet practice at 12.03. Exactly. And didn't she make them, when they went swimming, they'd all have to wear different swimming caps so that she could keep tabs on who was swimming well? She did. I mean, by the time Jack is going away to school, she's got about nine kids.
11点半关于政治的谈话，所有这类事情，房子的访客通常觉得这非常可怕且绝对令人不寒而栗。是的，12点03分的单簧管练习。正是如此。而且她不是让他们，当他们去游泳时，他们都必须戴不同的泳帽，这样她就能随时掌握谁游得好吗？她确实做了。我的意思是，当杰克去上学时，她已经有大约九个孩子了。
Plus, the other interesting thing from the family dynamic is that Joe is an absolutely inveterate womaniser. And he doesn't really bother to hide it from his children yes so he's having affairs with basically everyone kind of secretaries and waitresses and chambermaids and what kinds of but doesn't he also in a kind of foreshadowing of his son's relationship with marilyn monroe he has a relationship with glorious swanson who's a massive star in hollywood yes so joe kennedy goes to hollywood in the 1920s he starts up this relationship with Gloria Swanson, big film star. He does it under his family's nose. So the Swansons, that's Gloria and her husband, they even come with the Kennedys on holiday to Europe. And Joe is still carrying on with Gloria.
另外，家庭动态中另一个有趣的事情是，乔是一个绝对根深蒂固的女人。而且他并不真正费心向他的孩子们隐瞒这一点，是的，所以他基本上和每个人都有染，比如秘书、女服务员和女佣，还有什么样的人，但他在某种程度上预示了他儿子与玛丽莲·梦露的关系，他与格洛丽亚·斯旺森（Gloria Swanson）有关系，她是好莱坞的一位大明星，是的，所以乔·肯尼迪在20世纪20年代去了好莱坞，他开始了与格洛丽亚·斯旺森的关系，大电影明星。他在他家人的眼皮底下做这件事。所以斯旺森一家，也就是格洛丽亚和她的丈夫，他们甚至和肯尼迪一家一起去欧洲度假。而乔仍然在和格洛丽亚继续。
That's very Kaddish behaviour. And how does Mr. Swanson and Rose Kennedy, how do they feel about that? I'll be honest with you, my research stopped at Mr. Swanson, so I don't know how, what Mr. Swanson... I mean, is he getting out his horse whip or what's going on? No, clearly not. It's going off and playing a few rounds of golf or something, I think, Tom. But Rose Kennedy, she just completely turns a blind eye to it. She pretends it's not happening and doesn't admit it even to herself, I think.
那是非常卡迪什（Kaddish）的行为。斯旺森先生和罗斯·肯尼迪，他们对此感觉如何？老实说，我的研究在斯旺森先生那里就停止了，所以我不知道，斯旺森先生……我的意思是，他是在拿出他的马鞭还是发生了什么？不，显然不是。我想他是在去打几轮高尔夫球什么的，汤姆。但罗斯·肯尼迪，她完全对它视而不见。她假装它没有发生，我想她甚至对自己都不承认。
Because she's very devoutly Catholic, isn't she? She is, and she's a very introverted, serious person. And I think the Kennedy boys, they clearly got the message that this was fine and that your wife would always put up with it. Well, doesn't Joe encourage it? He's kind of, oh, lads, what have you been up to? He absolutely does.
因为她非常虔诚地信奉天主教，不是吗？她是，而且她是一个非常内向、严肃的人。我想肯尼迪男孩们，他们清楚地得到了这个信息，这是没问题的，而且你的妻子总是会忍受它。好吧，乔不是鼓励它吗？他有点，哦，小伙子们，你们一直在做什么？他绝对是。
And what is more, not only does Joe encourage it, but Joe will try to get in with their girlfriends as well. So he'll sometimes ring up Jack's girlfriends and take them out on a date and stuff. And then they sometimes say when he said goodbye, he was like 40 years my senior, but he would kiss me passionately on the lips. So, you know, the issue of JFK's womanizing has always sort of hung over him. But he was brought up to believe that it was natural, normal, acceptable. Chip off the old block. Absolutely. Absolutely. Anyway, we're jumping ahead. He goes to boarding schools. He goes to
而且更重要的是，乔不仅鼓励它，而且乔还会试图和他们的女朋友搞在一起。所以他有时会给杰克的女朋友打电话，带她们出去约会什么的。然后她们有时会说，当他告别时，他比我大40岁，但他会热情地吻我的嘴唇。所以，你知道，JFK的女人问题一直悬在他头上。但他从小就被教导相信这是自然的、正常的、可接受的。有其父必有其子。绝对是。绝对是。无论如何，我们跳得太远了。他去了寄宿学校。他去了
a Catholic boarding school first, and then he goes to a school called Choate. And Choate is a kind of, it's not the very highest echelon. Their very highest echelon wouldn't admit Catholics, but it's kind of the echelon just below it in public school terms it's minor major i think i'm glad you clarified that for us yes and actually at tote he's happy he's not brilliant academically because he's never terribly focused he's too dreamy and actually he's just has too much fun he's a prankster he's a japester climbing trees catapults all that kind of stuff pillow fights yeah you know very billy bunter tom stealing jam uh yes wrestling tramps but he's not fat is he no he's not fat quite the reverse quite the reverse and everyone loves him so yeah he's still a great reader so i was astounded
先是一所天主教寄宿学校，然后他去了一所叫乔特（Choate）的学校。乔特是一种，它不是最高阶层。他们的最高阶层不会录取天主教徒，但它是在公立学校术语中仅次于它的阶层，我想是次要主要，我很高兴你为我们澄清了这一点，是的，实际上在乔特他很开心，他在学术上并不出色，因为他从来没有非常专注，他太爱做梦了，实际上他只是玩得太开心了，他是一个恶作剧者，一个爱开玩笑的人，爬树、弹弓，所有这类东西，枕头大战，是的，你知道非常比利·邦特（Billy Bunter），汤姆，偷果酱，呃是的，摔跤流浪汉，但他不胖，不是吗？不，他不胖，恰恰相反，恰恰相反，每个人都爱他，所以是的，他仍然是一个伟大的读者，所以我很震惊
to read this the book he read as a teenager that transformed his life that he loved more than anything else was winston churchill's the world crisis about the first world war right well that is interesting because i mean he is of irish stock yeah and you know if there's one thing that irish bostonians are famous for it's their devotion to british imperial heroes they love them right and i know again i'm slightly jumping the gun here, but Joe Kennedy will go on to become ambassador to Britain in the build-up to the war and then through the Blitz. And it's marked by a certain degree of Anglophobia, isn't it? Well, I'm not sure whether he's Anglophobic. Well, okay. Hostility to Churchill. Yeah. He despises Churchill. He despises
读到这个，他十几岁时读的那本改变了他生活的书，他比任何东西都更爱的是温斯顿·丘吉尔的《世界危机》（The World Crisis），关于第一次世界大战，对吧，好吧，这很有趣，因为我的意思是，他是爱尔兰血统，是的，你知道如果爱尔兰波士顿人有什么出名的地方，那就是他们对英国帝国英雄的奉献，他们爱他们，对吧，我知道我再次稍微有点操之过急了，但乔·肯尼迪后来会成为战争前夕以及整个闪电战期间驻英国的大使。而且它带有某种程度的恐英症，不是吗？好吧，我不确定他是否恐英。好吧，好吧。对丘吉尔的敌意。是的。他鄙视丘吉尔。他鄙视
Churchill. He loves Neville Chamberlain. He greatly admires Neville Chamberlain. Jack Kennedy, I hadn't really appreciated the extent of this until reading up for this episode. Jack Kennedy is a passionate, passionate Anglophile. He loves English literature. He loves English history. And he loves English politicians and political traditions. And he loves Churchill, presumably. He loves Churchill more than anybody. So he starts reading about the First World War. Herbert Henry Asquith, who was listeners to our Writers History Club will remember, is undoubtedly one of the very great British prime ministers, Tom. Asquith said of the world crisis, Winston has written a book all about himself,
丘吉尔。他爱内维尔·张伯伦。他非常钦佩内维尔·张伯伦。杰克·肯尼迪，在阅读这一集的资料之前，我并没有真正意识到这一点。杰克·肯尼迪是一个充满激情的、充满激情的亲英派。他热爱英国文学。他热爱英国历史。他热爱英国政治家和政治传统。而且他热爱丘吉尔，大概。他比任何人都爱丘吉尔。所以他开始阅读关于第一次世界大战的书。赫伯特·亨利·阿斯奎斯（Herbert Henry Asquith），我们的《历史作家俱乐部》的听众会记得，毫无疑问是英国最伟大的首相之一，汤姆。阿斯奎斯曾评价《世界危机》，温斯顿写了一本关于他自己的书，
called it The World Crisis. But Kennedy thinks it's brilliant. And Kennedy is inspired by this to go on and read Churchill's massive million word biography of the Duke of Marlborough. I'm liking Kennedy more and more. He read a biography of Lord Melbourne and became absolutely a mad devotee of Lord Melbourne. That's Queen Victoria's prime minister. Queen Victoria's prime minister. And later on, Kennedy writes a book all about British politics in the 1930s, while England slept, all about Stanley Baldwin and Neville Chamberlain.
称之为《世界危机》。但肯尼迪认为它很精彩。肯尼迪受到启发，继续阅读丘吉尔那本百万字的马尔伯勒公爵传记。我越来越喜欢肯尼迪了。他读了墨尔本勋爵（Lord Melbourne）的传记，并成为了墨尔本勋爵的疯狂崇拜者。那是维多利亚女王的首相。维多利亚女王的首相。后来，肯尼迪写了一本关于20世纪30年代英国政治的书，《当英国沉睡时》（While England Slept），全是关于斯坦利·鲍德温（Stanley Baldwin）和内维尔·张伯伦的。
But Lord Melbourne, his wife, Lady Caroline Lamb, notoriously had a fling with Byron. She did, yeah. So maybe this is all part of the kind of aristocratic world that Kennedy is aspiring to. I think Kennedy and his family, they're very proud Americans, of course, but there's a part of him I think that would love to have been British. They like the style, they like the wit. Of course, Kennedy's sister marries a British aristocrat. He's always going on holiday to Britain, on trips to London, of course, France as well. His wife, Jackie, is a great Francophile. But Kennedy's anglophilia is a huge part of his character, I think. He wants
但墨尔本勋爵，他的妻子，卡罗琳·兰姆夫人（Lady Caroline Lamb），臭名昭著地与拜伦有过一段恋情。她确实有，是的。所以也许这都是肯尼迪所向往的那种贵族世界的一部分。我认为肯尼迪和他的家人，他们当然是非常自豪的美国人，但我想他的一部分会喜欢成为英国人。他们喜欢那种风格，他们喜欢那种机智。当然，肯尼迪的妹妹嫁给了一位英国贵族。他总是去英国度假，去伦敦旅行，当然还有法国。他的妻子杰基是一位伟大的亲法派。但我认为肯尼迪的亲英倾向是他性格中很大的一部分。他想
to be an English gentleman. He wants to be like a much more impressive Bertie Worcester. Well, except that Britain is very much on a downward spiral, even before the war, but obviously very much so after the war. And presumably Kennedy, I mean, the fact that he's American, and therefore there's the option that if you become president, then you are basically leader of the free world. I mean, that must be a crucial part of what's driving him as well, because they are thinking in those terms, aren't they? They absolutely are. Honey Fitz is saying about Joe, aka Biff, the elder brother, he's going to be president. And I mean, this isn't a joke. They're seriously aspiring to it. They're very passionate
成为一名英国绅士。他想成为一个更令人印象深刻的伯蒂·伍斯特（Bertie Wooster）。好吧，除了英国在战前就已经处于螺旋式下降中，但在战后显然更是如此。而且想必肯尼迪，我的意思是，他是美国人的事实，因此如果你成为总统，那么你基本上就是自由世界的领袖。我的意思是，那一定是他驱动力中至关重要的一部分，因为他们是在那种层面上思考的，不是吗？他们绝对是。“蜂蜜”菲茨在谈论乔，也就是比夫，哥哥时说，他将成为总统。我的意思是，这不是一个笑话。他们认真地向往它。他们非常充满激情
about it. There's always a slight sense with JFK that he goes into politics because, spoiler alert, Joe Jr., his elder brother, dies in the Second World War, and therefore he is the one who has to go into politics. But actually, it's very clear that Jack Kennedy was always passionate about politics. He's always reading books about world leaders and kings and prime ministers and presidents. And I think, as you say, he will end up seeing the United States as the successor to Britain, as the kind of leader of the Western world. He's very proud of that. And he wants to be the person who does it.
关于它。JFK总是有一种轻微的感觉，他进入政治是因为，剧透警告，乔·小，他的哥哥，在第二次世界大战中去世了，因此他是必须进入政治的那个人。但实际上，很明显杰克·肯尼迪一直对政治充满热情。他总是读关于世界领袖、国王、首相和总统的书。而且我想，正如你所说，他最终会把美国视为英国的继任者，作为西方世界的领袖。他对此感到非常自豪。而且他想成为那个做到这一点的人。
And he's always writing essays at school about leadership, about how you command a democracy, about how you handle international relations, all these kinds of things. I mean, he's really, really interested in it. So the image that I used to have of JFK, which I think I sort of absorbed from the academic historiography of the 90s, which was, he's a dilettante, he's an entitled, spoiled playboy. That's not really right. I mean, it is obvious that he's always, I mean, he's a dilettante, he's an entitled, spoiled playboy. That's not really right. I mean, it is obvious that he's always, I mean, he's not the world's deepest thinker. But he's thinking about it. Yeah, he is thinking about it.
而且他总是在学校写关于领导力的文章，关于你如何指挥一个民主国家，关于你如何处理国际关系，所有这类事情。我的意思是，他真的，真的对它很感兴趣。所以我曾经对JFK的形象，我想我从90年代的学术史学中吸收了这一点，即，他是一个业余爱好者，他是一个有权势的、被宠坏的花花公子。那并不完全正确。我的意思是，很明显他一直，我的意思是，他是一个业余爱好者，他是一个有权势的、被宠坏的花花公子。那并不完全正确。我的意思是，很明显他一直，我的意思是，他不是世界上最深刻的思想家。但他确实在思考它。是的，他确实在思考它。
So when Joe Kennedy gets appointed ambassador to Britain, he must have been thrilled by that. I think he absolutely was. He absolutely was. So he'd done quite well at school, but his school days had been blighted by these persistent illnesses. He's always been hospitalized with kind of irritable bowel syndrome, possible colitis, fevers, all of these kinds of things. And his back is still hurting him. He has a very bad back. By the time he leaves school, he's very popular.
所以当乔·肯尼迪被任命为驻英国大使时，他一定对此感到非常激动。我想他绝对是。他绝对是。所以他在学校表现得相当不错，但他的学校生活被这些持续的疾病所破坏。他总是因为某种肠易激综合征、可能的结肠炎、发烧、所有这类事情而住院。而且他的背仍然很痛。他有一个非常糟糕的背。当他离开学校时，他非常受欢迎。
The one thing everyone says about Jack Kennedy is that he's funny. He's really good company. He's charming. He's good-humored. He's a hit with the girls, all of these kinds of things. And then, as you say, his father is appointed by Franklin D. Roosevelt because his father was one of the only Wall Street executives who backed Roosevelt and the Democrats. So as a reward, his father is sent off to London to be the ambassador. And Jack, who has started out at
每个人对杰克·肯尼迪说的一件事就是他很有趣。他是一个很好的伙伴。他很有魅力。他很有幽默感。他是女孩们的最爱，所有这类事情。然后，正如你所说，他的父亲被富兰克林·D·罗斯福任命，因为他的父亲是唯一支持罗斯福和民主党的华尔街高管之一。所以作为奖励，他的父亲被派往伦敦担任大使。而杰克，他已经开始在
Harvard, he goes and spends a lot of time in London. By the way, Tom, he did French in his first year at Harvard. Do you know what his essay choice was for his extended essay? I do, because I've seen your notes. Yeah. François Premier. Exactly. The life of Francis I. The dashing, womanising King of France who met Henry VIII at the Field of the Cloth of Gold. And do you know what mark he got, though?
哈佛，他去伦敦花了很多时间。顺便说一句，汤姆，他在哈佛的第一年选修了法语。你知道他长篇论文的选题是什么吗？我知道，因为我看了你的笔记。是的。弗朗索瓦一世（François Premier）。正是如此。法国那位潇洒、风流的国王，他在金缕衣原野（Field of the Cloth of Gold）会见了亨利八世。但你知道他得了什么分数吗？
Did he fail? He got a D+, and his biographer, Fred Logevall, who wrote a tremendous biography and is in fact a tremendous fellow. Fred Logevall thinks that today standards have fallen so much, Tom, they would get a B. Oh, good. But back then it got a D. So he spends loads of time in Britain. In fact, not just Britain. He goes to Germany. He goes to Nuremberg. He goes to Italy and he sees the Mussolini rally. So does he see the Nuremberg rally?
他不及格了吗？他得了一个D+，他的传记作者弗雷德·洛格瓦尔，他写了一本了不起的传记，实际上是一个了不起的人。弗雷德·洛格瓦尔认为，如果以今天的标准来看，标准已经下降了这么多，汤姆，他们会得一个B。哦，太好了。但当时它得了一个D。所以他在英国花了很多时间。事实上，不仅仅是英国。他去了德国。他去了纽伦堡。他去了意大利，他看到了墨索里尼的集会。所以他看到了纽伦堡集会吗？
Not a Nuremberg rally, but he sort of visits Nuremberg, which is all decked out in- Yeah, swastikas and things. Yeah. He went to, I mean, I'm just looking at the list of countries. Poland, Russia, Turkey, Greece, Egypt, Palestine, Lebanon, Bulgaria, Romania, Yugoslavia. I mean, extraordinary apprenticeship for somebody who is interested in politics and is 20, 21. So when his dad becomes ambassador to Britain, is he in London with his dad? Has he got a kind of ringside view of all the drama of appeasement and all that kind of stuff?
不是纽伦堡集会，但他某种程度上访问了纽伦堡，那里到处都是——是的，万字旗和东西。是的。他去了，我的意思是，我只是在看国家名单。波兰、俄罗斯、土耳其、希腊、埃及、巴勒斯坦、黎巴嫩、保加利亚、罗马尼亚、南斯拉夫。我的意思是，对于一个对政治感兴趣且20、21岁的人来说，这是一次非凡的学徒生涯。所以当他父亲成为驻英国大使时，他和父亲在伦敦吗？他是否对绥靖政策的所有戏剧性事件等等有某种前排视角？
Yeah, he does often on Tom. He's at Harvard as well. So he's kind of coming and going. And as Britain slides towards war, now, interestingly, his father, Joe, is very isolationist, is desperate for Britain not to get involved in the war, is actually spending loads of time and kind of emotional investment in Neville Chamberlain and Neville Chamberlain's policy of appeasing Hitler. And Jack, it's clear, does not really agree with his father because he's this kind of romantic swashbuckling Churchill fan. This is the point at which he starts to break with his father, I would say, as war approaches. Then, of course, war breaks out in 1939. Joe Kennedy is devastated by this. He rings Chamberlain and is virtually in tears that Chamberlain has been forced to take Britain into war. Joe Kennedy absolutely agrees
是的，他经常在，汤姆。他也在哈佛。所以他某种程度上来来去去。随着英国滑向战争，现在，有趣的是，他的父亲乔非常孤立主义，非常渴望英国不要卷入战争，实际上在内维尔·张伯伦和内维尔·张伯伦安抚希特勒的政策上投入了大量的时间和情感投资。而杰克，很明显，并不真正同意他父亲的观点，因为他是那种浪漫的、冒险的丘吉尔粉丝。这是他开始与父亲决裂的点，我会说，随着战争的临近。然后，当然，战争在1939年爆发了。乔·肯尼迪对此感到崩溃。他给张伯伦打电话，几乎泪流满面，因为张伯伦被迫将英国带入战争。乔·肯尼迪绝对同意
with you, by the way, that Britain is on its uppers. Yeah, well, he famously says, doesn't he, democracy is finished in England. Yeah, in that voice. And also in the Blitz, he leaves London and Churchill's son Randolph says something to the effect of, I always thought daffodils were yellow till I met Joe Kennedy. Oh, very good. Very good. Yeah. He ends up being largely despised. Certainly the people around Churchill absolutely despise him. So when Churchill comes in as prime minister, Joe Kennedy is distraught. He describes him as an actor and a politician. He obviously is a politician, but Joe Kennedy despises him.
你的观点，顺便说一句，英国处于衰落中。是的，好吧，他著名地说，不是吗，民主在英国已经结束了。是的，用那种声音。而且在闪电战中，他离开了伦敦，丘吉尔的儿子伦道夫（Randolph）说了类似这样的话：我一直以为水仙花是黄色的，直到我见到乔·肯尼迪。哦，非常好。非常好。是的。他最终被广泛鄙视。当然，丘吉尔周围的人绝对鄙视他。所以当丘吉尔担任首相时，乔·肯尼迪心烦意乱。他形容他是一个演员和一个政治家。他显然是一个政治家，但乔·肯尼迪鄙视他。
Churchill apparently inflames Joe Kennedy by constantly offering him drinks. Because he's a teetotaler. Because he drinks very little. In fact, Jack Kennedy drinks very little as well. Right. And Churchill makes a point of ostentatiously forgetting it and always pouring him glasses of brandy. Anyway, Tom, I think we should take a break.
丘吉尔显然通过不断给他提供饮料来激怒乔·肯尼迪。因为他是一个禁酒主义者。因为他喝得很少。事实上，杰克·肯尼迪也喝得很少。对。而且丘吉尔特意炫耀性地忘记了这一点，总是给他倒白兰地。无论如何，汤姆，我想我们应该休息一下。
And when we come back after the break, we should get Jack Kennedy into the war because he emerges as this extraordinary kind of war hero. Okay. So we'll take a break now. And when we come back, JFK, war hero. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. JFK, war hero. sister live tickets head to the rest is entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com
当我们休息回来后，我们应该让杰克·肯尼迪进入战争，因为他作为这种非凡的战争英雄出现了。好的。所以我们现在休息一下。当我们回来时，JFK，战争英雄。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。JFK，战争英雄。姐妹现场门票前往 therestisentertainment.com，那是 therestisentertainment.com
hello welcome back to the rest is history and we are talking about the upbringing of john f kennedy or dominic as he was known by friend and family, Jack. In the interval, we've been bollocked by Theo, who doesn't understand that John and Jack are the same person. So we just want to make it absolutely clear for one and all that John and Jack Kennedy are the same person. That Joe Kennedy is his dad and that Joe Jr. I think we should just call him Biff. John Jack Kennedy's elder brother, Biff, from now on. I just think it would simplify things. Okay. So war breaks out.
你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》，我们正在谈论约翰·F·肯尼迪的成长经历，或者多米尼克所说的，朋友和家人称他为杰克。在间歇期间，我们被西奥（Theo）训斥了，他不明白约翰和杰克是同一个人。所以我们只想为所有人明确一点，约翰和杰克·肯尼迪是同一个人。乔·肯尼迪是他的父亲，而小乔，我想我们应该直接叫他比夫。约翰·杰克·肯尼迪的哥哥，比夫，从现在开始。我只是觉得这会简化事情。好的。所以战争爆发了。
Jack Kennedy then, he doesn't go straight into the war. He goes back and he writes his senior thesis, Tom at Harvard, which ends up being published as a book. And it's a history of appeasement. And it's a history of the national government in the 1930s. Some people might say a very unglamorous subject for such a glamorous man. But the tremendous thing about this and why it's very important that we mention it and that everybody reflect upon it and draw the appropriate lessons is that he has a lot of time for Stanley
杰克·肯尼迪，他没有直接进入战争。他回去写了他的毕业论文，汤姆，在哈佛，最终作为一本书出版了。这是一部关于绥靖政策的历史。这是一部关于20世纪30年代国民政府的历史。有些人可能会说，对于这样一个迷人的男人来说，这是一个非常不迷人的主题。但关于这一点，以及为什么我们提到它并让每个人反思并吸取适当教训非常重要，令人惊叹的是，他对斯坦利·鲍德温（Stanley Baldwin）有很多时间
Baldwin. Dominic, I'm glad you've got that in. That's excellent. But let's move on. It's shocking. I had so much more to say about that, Tom. But we're moving on. We're moving on. Because meanwhile, Dominic, the storm clouds of war are gathering over the United States, aren't they? America enters the war. How does this impact on JFK? So even before Pearl Harbor, JFK has been drafted and he has gone off to the Office of Naval Intelligence in Washington, DC. And actually before he goes off to fight, he is involved with one of these sort of mysterious interludes, Tom,
多米尼克，我很高兴你提到了这一点。那太棒了。但让我们继续。这令人震惊。我还有很多关于那个的话要说，汤姆。但我们继续前进。我们继续前进。因为与此同时，多米尼克，战争的乌云正在美国上空聚集，不是吗？美国参战。这对JFK有什么影响？所以甚至在珍珠港事件之前，JFK就已经被征召入伍，他去了华盛顿特区的海军情报局。实际上在他去战斗之前，他卷入了这些神秘的插曲之一，汤姆，
in his early life. So he's already lots of girlfriends. He's actually already had venereal disease, which has left him with a kind of unshakable urethritis infection. Unshakable is perhaps not the word. No, unfortunate word. So his terrible little health continues. Anyway, he ends up meeting a Danish journalist called Inge Arvad. He calls her Ingebinger. And she is very glamorous. She's older than he is, four years older, already on her second marriage. She's kind of blonde and charming and sophisticated. And I don't think it's an exaggeration to say she really is the love of his life. I mean, of course, he later has Jackie, but it's
在他早年生活中。所以他已经有很多女朋友了。他实际上已经患过性病，这给他留下了一种无法治愈的尿道炎感染。无法治愈也许不是合适的词。不，这个词用得不恰当。总之，他糟糕的健康状况仍在持续。无论如何，他最终遇到了一位名叫英格·阿瓦德的丹麦记者。他叫她“英格宾格”。她非常有魅力。她比他大，大四岁，已经是第二次婚姻了。她金发碧眼，迷人而世故。我认为说她是他的挚爱并不夸张。我的意思是，当然，他后来有了杰基，但
Inger Arvad that he falls head over heels for. And the issue here is that Inger Arvad had interviewed Adolf Hitler in 1935 and written this very Milton Boone, kind of Barbara Cartland style thing about Hitler's mesmeric eyes. Very Unity Mitford behavior. Very Unity Mitford. And then Hitler had even invited her to sit next to him in his box at the Berlin Olympics, or at least to sit very close to him. So she had these associations. Of course, she's a Dane, so she speaks German. She knows lots of Germans. The FBI become very concerned that she is carrying on with the ambassador's son. And they place wiretaps on Kennedy and Inger. So this is in 1942. Because they think she's a spy.
英格·阿瓦德才是让他神魂颠倒的人。这里的问题是，英格·阿瓦德曾在1935年采访过阿道夫·希特勒，并写了一篇非常米尔顿·布恩（Milton Boone）、类似芭芭拉·卡特兰（Barbara Cartland）风格的文章，描写希特勒那迷人的眼睛。非常像尤妮蒂·米特福德（Unity Mitford）的行为。非常像尤妮蒂·米特福德。而且希特勒甚至邀请她坐在柏林奥运会他的包厢里，或者至少是坐在离他很近的地方。所以她有这些关联。当然，她是丹麦人，所以她会说德语。她认识很多德国人。联邦调查局（FBI）非常担心她与大使的儿子有染。于是他们在肯尼迪和英格的电话上安装了窃听器。这是在1942年。因为他们认为她是间谍。
Because they think she might be a spy. Actually, it seems pretty clear she's not a Nazi agent. He's not telling her anything. He doesn't have access to any very exciting information anyway. He, at worst, is being a little bit naive, but actually probably not even being naive because she's not actually a spy. But that relationship, it doesn't lead anywhere. But I think that gives you an indication of the kind of person he is. He loves having a sophisticated older woman as his lover. He loves the thought of a European wife. I mean, of course, Jackie is a great Francophile, and that sort of European-ness is very important to him about her later on. Anyway, the thing with Inga Arvad breaks up. He goes off to midshipman school in the summer of
因为他们认为她可能是个间谍。事实上，她似乎很明显不是纳粹特工。他什么都没告诉她。反正他也没法接触到什么令人兴奋的信息。他充其量只是有点天真，但实际上可能连天真都算不上，因为她根本不是间谍。但那段关系并没有什么结果。但我认为这让你了解了他是一个什么样的人。他喜欢有一个世故的年长女性作为情人。他喜欢欧洲妻子的想法。我的意思是，当然，杰基非常热爱法国文化，那种欧洲气质对他来说在后来非常重要。无论如何，他和英格·阿瓦德的事情结束了。他在1942年夏天去了海军候补军官学校。
1942. His great dream is to command what's called a PT boat, which is a torpedo boat, these little boats with maybe a dozen people on them, kind of scooting around the South Pacific. He is already in tremendous pain with his back. His back is in a terrible state. Basically, his spine is collapsing. I mean, could he have been invalided out? Is it kind of one of the things where he's pulling strings? Yes, I think there is a bit of string pulling, actually. I think plausibly, if he'd been that desperate to avoid it, he could have probably done so. But he is desperate to go.
他最大的梦想是指挥所谓的PT艇，也就是鱼雷艇，这些小船上可能只有十几个人，在南太平洋上四处穿梭。他的背部已经非常疼痛。他的背部状况糟糕透顶。基本上，他的脊椎正在塌陷。我的意思是，他本可以因伤退役吗？这是否属于那种他动用关系的情况？是的，我认为实际上确实动用了一点关系。我认为如果他真的那么绝望地想逃避，他可能确实能做到。但他渴望去参战。
Which reflects very well on his patriotism and courage. What also reflects well on him, Tom, just to talk about his personality for a second, off he goes to the war. He has had a very, very spoiled upbringing. Millionaire son, Rolls Royces, yachts, Cape Cod, Harvard, boarding school, not always accepted into the very, very highest, most exclusive clubs and stuff, but accepted by a lot of them. Once for nothing, he's been favoured by fortune because he's very good looking and funny and he's bright and all this stuff. But all the men who serve with him, they love him. They think he's great fun, a great character. He doesn't drink with them and play cards. Nixon, when he went off to the war, he was well known for the kind of playing cards and stuff. Kennedy doesn't
这很好地反映了他的爱国精神和勇气。汤姆，还有一点也很好地反映了他的性格，稍微谈谈他的个性，他去参加战争了。他有着非常、非常优越的成长环境。百万富翁的儿子，劳斯莱斯，游艇，科德角，哈佛，寄宿学校，虽然并不总是被最顶尖、最排他的俱乐部接纳，但还是被其中许多接纳了。他从未求过什么，他一直受到命运的眷顾，因为他长得帅、风趣、聪明，诸如此类。但所有与他一起服役的人都喜欢他。他们认为他非常有趣，是个了不起的人物。他不和他们一起喝酒打牌。尼克松去参战时，以打牌之类的活动而闻名。肯尼迪并不
really do that. He likes to sit and read. But they still like him. They like him because he's very friendly. And so this presumably bodes well for a future political career. Does exactly. If he's got that common touch. He does indeed. Hey, do you know what books he took with him to the South Pacific? I do.
真的那样做。他喜欢坐着看书。但他们仍然喜欢他。他们喜欢他，因为他非常友好。所以这大概预示着他未来的政治生涯会很顺利。确实如此。如果他有那种亲民的特质。他确实有。嘿，你知道他带了什么书去南太平洋吗？我知道。
He took Bunyan with him, didn't he? Pilgrim's Progress. Is that right? No. That shows to me that you have read the notes that I sent you. And I said you didn't need to read. But you haven't read them as closely as you could have done. He read John Buchan's memoir, Pilgrim's Way.
他带了班扬（Bunyan）的书，对吧？《天路历程》（Pilgrim's Progress）。是这样吗？不。这向我表明你读了我发给你的笔记。而我说过你不需要读。但你读得不够仔细。他读的是约翰·布肯（John Buchan）的回忆录《朝圣之路》（Pilgrim's Way）。
Oh, I think the less of him then. I thought it was John Bunyan. I saw Bunyan, I saw a JP, Pilgrim, and my brain did the rest. That's very Tom Holland. But he also took War and Peace and read that. Well, I guess if you're stuck in a submarine for, what, weeks at a time. In a torpedo boat. Yeah, that's what he was thinking.
哦，那我对他评价降低了。我以为是约翰·班扬。我看到了班扬，看到了JP，朝圣者，我的大脑就自动补全了。这很汤姆·霍兰德。但他还带了《战争与和平》并读了它。好吧，我想如果你被困在潜艇里，一次待上几周的话。是在鱼雷艇上。是的，他当时就是这么想的。
Now, what happens next is really the making of him politically. So on the night of the 1st of August 1943, he's commanding his little boat zipping around the South Pacific. And basically, a Japanese destroyer crashes into their boat in the middle of the ocean and cuts it in half. So two of his crew are killed or lost is that his fault it's slightly his fault he kind of should have seen the destroyer yeah i mean i mean secretly the destroyer's fault right i mean it's kind of a crash yeah but the destroyer is a destroyer
现在，接下来发生的事情真正成就了他的政治地位。1943年8月1日晚上，他指挥着他的小船在南太平洋上穿梭。基本上，一艘日本驱逐舰在海洋中央撞上了他们的船，把它撞成了两半。所以他的两名船员死亡或失踪，这是他的错吗？这稍微有点他的错，他本应该看到那艘驱逐舰的。是的，我的意思是，暗地里是驱逐舰的错，对吧？我的意思是，这算是一场碰撞，是的，但驱逐舰毕竟是驱逐舰。
yes yeah exactly well it is slightly his fault anyway what happens next is very impressive so he and 10 of the others survive. The boat is there in debris. They're kind of bobbing around in the darkness. He decides they'll all swim to this coral island nearby that he can just see vaguely on the horizon. And is this because the destroyer has just plowed on, has barely even noticed it? Yeah, the destroyer's kept going. So they're just going to sink.
是的，没错，确实，这稍微有点他的错。无论如何，接下来发生的事情非常令人印象深刻，他和另外10个人幸存了下来。船只变成了残骸。他们在黑暗中漂浮着。他决定他们都要游到附近的一个珊瑚岛，他隐约能在地平线上看到那个岛。这是因为驱逐舰已经开走了，几乎没注意到吗？是的，驱逐舰继续前行了。所以他们只能沉没。
He basically tells some of his men, hold on to this big plank. And then he gets another one, a guy called McMahon, who's been badly injured. And he's in a life jacket. He's an engineer. And Kennedy puts the strap of the life jacket in his teeth and swims, dragging him with his teeth using this strap. I mean, that's hard work. Yeah, that is hard work, isn't it? Especially if basically you have no back. Yeah. And it takes him four hours. Four hours, Tom, swimming through the darkness. And the island is called Plum Pudding Island, isn't it? Yes. They move on different islands.
他基本上告诉他的一些手下，抓住这块大木板。然后他找到了另一个人，一个叫麦克马洪（McMahon）的家伙，他受了重伤。他穿着救生衣。他是一名工程师。肯尼迪把救生衣的带子咬在牙齿里，用牙齿拖着他游。我的意思是，那可是苦差事。是的，那确实是苦差事，不是吗？尤其是如果你基本上没有背部支撑的话。是的。他花了四个小时。四个小时，汤姆，在黑暗中游泳。那个岛叫李子布丁岛（Plum Pudding Island），对吧？是的。他们后来转移到了不同的岛屿。
So they all get to the island and Kennedy says, we need to get help. I'll have to just swim out and hang around, try and attract attention from passing US torpedo boats. But that doesn't work. They all go to another island. Again, he's towing this bloke with his teeth. Then on this other island, Tom, and this is a detail that Hollywood scriptwriter would love and indeed did love, they meet a couple of blokes who are like native South Pacific islanders in canoes.
所以他们都到了岛上，肯尼迪说，我们需要寻求帮助。我得游出去待着，试着吸引过往美国鱼雷艇的注意。但这没用。他们都去了另一个岛。同样，他还是用牙齿拖着那个家伙。然后在另一个岛上，汤姆，这是一个好莱坞编剧会喜欢、而且确实喜欢的细节，他们遇到了几个当地的南太平洋岛民，划着独木舟。
This very Captain Cook. Kennedy gives them a message, which he writes on a coconut, which they take to some Australians and eventually they end up being rescued. And so how long are they kind of on the island? Golly, days and days. I mean, they're not there for months. And what are they eating? Is there food?
这非常像库克船长。肯尼迪给了他们一条信息，他写在一个椰子上，他们把椰子带给了一些澳大利亚人，最终他们获救了。那么他们在岛上待了多久？天哪，好几天。我的意思是，他们并没有在那里待上几个月。他们吃什么？有食物吗？
I mean, are they... I don't know all the details of this. Are they eating coconuts, I suppose? I suppose they must eat some coconuts, shrubs, beetles. Maybe they've got some rations. Lizards. I mean, you're asking for information I don't possess. But the fact of the matter is, even though the Kennedy kind of machine
我的意思是，他们……我不知道这方面的所有细节。我想他们是在吃椰子吧？我想他们一定吃了一些椰子、灌木、甲虫。也许他们有一些口粮。蜥蜴。我的意思是，你在问我不知道的信息。但事实是，尽管肯尼迪的机器
later massively romanticised and sensationalised this story, it did happen. He is incredibly brave. And it is incredibly brave and very, very impressive. It also took a toll on his health that never, ever left him. So it leaves him with yet more fevers, hideous ulcers. He gets malaria. And he arguably never recovered from the malaria at all.
后来极大地浪漫化和夸大了这个故事，但它确实发生了。他非常勇敢。这确实非常勇敢，也非常令人印象深刻。这也对他的健康造成了永远无法磨灭的损害。所以这给他留下了更多的发烧、可怕的溃疡。他得了疟疾。而且可以说他从未从疟疾中完全恢复过来。
And does it get written up and make him a kind of a war hero back in America? It absolutely does. It ends up in the Reader's Digest. Oh, so Reagan. Ronald Reagan would undoubtedly have read this story, Tom. Right, right. The one person who it's bad for is the fellow you call Biff, Sir Joe Jr. Oh, because he blows up over Suffolk, doesn't he?
这事被报道出来，让他成为了美国的一种战争英雄吗？绝对是。它最终登上了《读者文摘》。哦，所以里根。罗纳德·里根无疑读过这个故事，汤姆。对，对。唯一一个因此感到糟糕的人是你所说的“比夫”（Biff），小乔·肯尼迪（Joe Jr.）。哦，因为他在萨福克郡上空爆炸了，对吧？
He does. In the Air Force. In the Air Force. So he has been over suffolk doesn't he he does in the air force in the air force so he has been put in the shade by this totally put in the shade and people sort of say well you know that gave him this drive to do better and he ends up volunteering for this mission called operation anvil which is basically your flyer plane packed with explosives yeah into kind of german bases and you'll parachute out at the last minute what could possibly go wrong so something does go wrong in august 1944 the thing explodes joe jr is killed what this does for jack he's now the eldest and he is now free to pursue the political career so when he goes back at the end of world war ii he is a big hero so he has become a kind of household name
是的。在空军。在空军。所以他被这个完全掩盖了光芒，完全被掩盖了，人们会说，好吧，你知道，这给了他做得更好的动力，他最终志愿参加了一个名为“铁砧行动”（Operation Anvil）的任务，基本上就是让你驾驶一架装满炸药的飞机，撞向德国基地，然后在最后一刻跳伞逃生，这能出什么错呢？所以确实出了错，1944年8月，飞机爆炸了，小乔死了。这对杰克意味着什么？他现在是长子了，他现在可以自由地追求政治生涯了。所以当他在二战结束时回来时，他是一个大英雄，所以他已经成为了家喻户晓的名字。
because if you've got into Reader's Digest, tens and tens of millions of people will have seen your story. He's the son of the former ambassador. They're a very glamorous family. He's very good looking. He's charming. Everything is in his favor. The one thing that's not in his favor, which is so easy to miss, I think, when you're seduced by the Camelot legend is the terrible health. So for the 10 years or so after the war, I mean, he could have died multiple times. He spends time in comas. He's read the last rights. He never actually recovers from the experience of the South Pacific, from the exhaustion, from the malaria and all that stuff. Anyway, people don't see that in Boston in 1946,
因为如果你登上了《读者文摘》，成千上万的人都会看到你的故事。他是前大使的儿子。他们是一个非常有魅力的家庭。他长得很帅。他很有魅力。一切都对他有利。唯一对他不利的，我认为在被卡米洛特（Camelot）传说吸引时很容易忽略的，就是他糟糕的健康状况。所以战后大约10年里，我的意思是，他可能多次死亡。他花时间在昏迷中。他接受了临终祈祷。他从未真正从南太平洋的经历、从疲劳、从疟疾和所有这些事情中恢复过来。无论如何，人们在1946年的波士顿并没有看到这一点，
when he decides to run as a Democrat from the 11th Congressional District. Why a Democrat? Because they've always been a Democrat family. The Democrats have always been the party of Irish Catholics. It wouldn't even be a decision. You wouldn't need to think about it at all. But does it also reflect conscious thought about what the Democrats are about? Absolutely, yes. Yes. He has come out of the war unlike his father. He is a passionate internationalist. So in his big biography, Fred Loge has come out of the war unlike his father. He is a passionate internationalist. So in his big biography, Fred Logevill says of Kennedy, if you don't understand the impact of the Second World War on him, you miss everything. The Second World War is everything. He loves
当他决定作为民主党人竞选第11国会选区的议员时。为什么是民主党？因为他们一直是一个民主党家庭。民主党一直是爱尔兰天主教徒的政党。这甚至不需要决定。你根本不需要考虑它。但这是否也反映了关于民主党主张的自觉思考？绝对是，是的。是的。他从战争中走出来，不像他的父亲。他是一位充满激情的国际主义者。所以在他那本大传记中，弗雷德·洛格瓦尔（Fred Logevall）说肯尼迪，如果你不了解第二次世界大战对他产生的影响，你就错过了所有的一切。第二次世界大战就是一切。他热爱
Churchill. He absolutely thinks America should be part of the world. He believes in fighting crusades for freedom against international evil. He's been in the military. He believes in courage and not in appeasement. All of that sort of stuff is kind of seared into his soul. And he wants to take that into politics. He also believes in a kind of slightly vague, amorphous way, I think, in public service, in using the power of the government in a sort of restrained way to do good. So he's not a radical Democrat, a radical liberal or anything like that. He is a pragmatic, sensible, left of center by American standards, liberal Democrat. This is the kind of invidious question because it's, I'm sure, impossible to answer. But do you think his motivation, is it primarily political? Is he motivated by political ideals
丘吉尔。他绝对认为美国应该是世界的一部分。他相信为自由而战，反对国际邪恶。他曾在军队服役。他相信勇气，而不是绥靖政策。所有这些东西都深深烙印在他的灵魂里。他想把这些带入政治。他还以一种稍微模糊、无形的方式，我认为，相信公共服务，以一种克制的方式利用政府的力量来做好事。所以他不是一个激进的民主党人，激进的自由派或类似的人。他是一个务实、明智、按美国标准属于中左翼的自由派民主党人。这是一个令人反感的问题，因为我相信这不可能回答。但你认为他的动机，主要是政治性的吗？他是被政治理想所驱动，
or is he motivated by a sense that he should become president because this is what his daddy and his granddaddy want him to do? That is a tough question to answer, Tom. I mean, maybe they're so interfused that you can't really distinguish them. I think they're really interfused. I actually think it's too easy to point to the latter. Dismiss him as entitled. Yeah. Golden spoon in his mouth.
还是被一种他应该成为总统的感觉所驱动，因为这是他爸爸和爷爷希望他做的？这是一个很难回答的问题，汤姆。我的意思是，也许它们融合得太紧密了，你无法真正区分它们。我认为它们确实融合在一起了。我实际上认为指出后者太容易了。把他斥为有权势的人。是的。含着金汤匙出生。
He's an entitled little brass who just wants to please daddy his teachers at harvard the friends he makes all of these people of course there's always a degree of them being dazzled by his wealth i mean his best friend is a guy called len billings who actually was gay and had a crush on jack kennedy but people like len billings they don't think he's just a spoiled daddy's boy they think of him as a person who will sit up late at night over the one glass, because he's not a big drinker, or over a cigar, talking about what is the role of government in a world competing between democracy and communism. And he's interested, isn't he, both in ideas and in talking to people? And that seems so important for successful politicians.
他是一个有权势的小混蛋，只想取悦爸爸、他在哈佛的老师、他结交的朋友，所有这些人，当然，他们总是会被他的财富所迷惑。我的意思是，他最好的朋友是一个叫伦·比林斯（Len Billings）的家伙，他实际上是同性恋，暗恋杰克·肯尼迪，但像伦·比林斯这样的人，他们不认为他只是一个被宠坏的爸爸的男孩，他们认为他是一个会深夜坐着，喝着一杯酒（因为他不怎么喝酒），或者抽着雪茄，谈论在民主与共产主义竞争的世界中政府的角色是什么的人。他很感兴趣，不是吗？既对想法感兴趣，也对与人交谈感兴趣。这对于成功的政治家来说似乎非常重要。
Yeah. To have that combination. Yes, absolutely. So he meets with Nixon, doesn't he? When he becomes a congressman, he does. Yeah. So when he starts out, like a lot of people, he's young, he's 29 when he's elected, turns 30 in his first year in Congress. He looks kind of skeletal because he's lost all this weight and he's had all this malaria. And he's stiff at first and finds speaking difficult and stuff. But he quickly picks it up. He's very popular on the campaign trail. He's very charming. He's funny. He's bright. He's not a kind of just a posh airhead by any means. And as you say,
是的。拥有这种组合。是的，绝对。所以他遇到了尼克松，不是吗？当他成为国会议员时，他确实遇到了。是的。所以当他刚开始时，像许多人一样，他很年轻，当选时才29岁，在国会的第一年就满30岁了。他看起来有点骨瘦如柴，因为他体重减轻了很多，而且患过所有这些疟疾。起初他很僵硬，觉得说话很困难之类的。但他很快就学会了。他在竞选活动中非常受欢迎。他非常有魅力。他很有趣。他很聪明。他绝不是那种时髦的空心人。正如你所说，
when he goes into Congress, he gets on pretty well with Nixon. So Nixon, similar story, been in the Navy, been in the Pacific, newly married, the young family, they get on well. There's a famous story about them doing a debate together in pennsylvania in 1947 then they get the train back to washington together the late night train they're kind of in a compartment the two of them young guys early 30s chewing the fat they are chewing the fat putting the world to rights they are that's exactly what they're doing tom they're just wittering on to each other about foreign policy and communism and all this kind of thing and nixon tells that story later in life in a slightly kind of romanticized way. Jack and I were great friends and all this stuff. But there's no reason really to doubt it.
当他进入国会时，他和尼克松相处得很好。所以尼克松，类似的故事，在海军服役过，在太平洋待过，新婚，年轻的家庭，他们相处得很好。有一个关于他们在1947年宾夕法尼亚州一起辩论的著名故事，然后他们一起坐火车回华盛顿，深夜的火车，他们俩在一个车厢里，年轻的家伙，30出头，闲聊。他们在闲聊，纠正世界。他们确实是这样，汤姆，他们只是在向对方唠叨外交政策、共产主义和所有这些事情，尼克松后来在生活中以一种稍微浪漫化的方式讲述了这个故事。杰克和我曾是好朋友之类的。但真的没有理由怀疑它。
It talons what we know of their respective characters. It sounds entirely likely, yeah. So he's making his way through Congress and it's being perennially punctuated by these health episodes. So in 1947, he's diagnosed with Addison's disease. Addison's disease is basically, it's a failure of your adrenal glands, and it means that you are very weak. You've got very low blood pressure. Your skin looks kind of yellowish and brownish, which actually JFK's skin, if you look at color photos of him later, it does. And it makes it very hard for you to fight infections.
这与我们所知的他们各自的性格相符。听起来完全有可能，是的。所以他正在国会中前进，并且不断地被这些健康问题所打断。所以1947年，他被诊断出患有阿狄森氏病（Addison's disease）。阿狄森氏病基本上是肾上腺功能衰竭，这意味着你非常虚弱。你的血压很低。你的皮肤看起来有点发黄发褐，实际上JFK的皮肤，如果你看他后来的彩色照片，确实如此。这使得你很难抵抗感染。
And that's a problem if you've got lots of other things going wrong. It's unbelievable. He's doing all this stuff and he's as ill and in as much pain as he is. Well, later on in 1954, his back has collapsed so much that the doctors say to him, you will basically be in a wheelchair unless we do emergency surgery. We're going to have to do this spinal fusion surgery, which is very experimental, and we're going to have to put in a metal plate. The downside is that this kind of operation makes it very likely you'll get an infection. But because of your Addison's disease, the infection could well kill you. And he goes
如果你还有很多其他问题，那是个问题。这令人难以置信。他做着所有这些事情，而且他病得这么重，承受着这么大的痛苦。好吧，后来在1954年，他的背部塌陷得太厉害了，医生告诉他，除非我们做紧急手术，否则你基本上会坐轮椅。我们必须做这种脊柱融合手术，这非常具有实验性，我们必须植入一块金属板。缺点是这种手术让你很有可能感染。但因为你有阿狄森氏病，感染很可能会要了你的命。他还是
ahead with the operation anyway, and actually he ends up almost dying. And he has to lie on his back for weeks in a darkened room. There's a big benefit to this, actually. It means he misses the Senate vote on censoring Joe McCarthy, the anti-communist firebrand. So he doesn't have to censor McCarthy. And that plays well with his sort of Irish working class constituents who think McCarthy's a great guy. The Green Wall. I think there's a lot of resentments and jealousy of him. First, when he's a congressman, then when he's a senator from 1953 onwards. There's always this resentment. People think he's had everything handed to him to play. The Kennedys always outspend their rivals in campaigns 10 to 1. And liberals say, oh, well, he didn't condemn Joe McCarthy. He didn't do this, that, I think when you stand back and look at him, he's a very good politician. He's very bright.
进行了手术，实际上他最终差点死了。他不得不躺在黑暗的房间里几周。这实际上有一个很大的好处。这意味着他错过了参议院关于谴责反共煽动者乔·麦卡锡（Joe McCarthy）的投票。所以他不必谴责麦卡锡。这在他那些认为麦卡锡是个好人的爱尔兰工人阶级选民中很受欢迎。绿色长城。我认为人们对他有很多怨恨和嫉妒。起初，当他还是国会议员时，然后从1953年起当参议员时。总是有这种怨恨。人们认为他的一切都是别人给他的。肯尼迪家族在竞选中的支出总是比对手高出10倍。自由派说，哦，好吧，他没有谴责乔·麦卡锡。他没有做这个那个，我认为当你退后一步看他时，他是一个非常好的政治家。他非常聪明。
He's clearly on the sort of more pragmatic liberal wing of the Democratic Party. He's well-liked. He's a good package. And once he's sorted his health out, he's clearly going to be a player in sort of frontline politics. But Dominic, a frontline politician needs a wife, right? Very good point, Tom. Very good point. He does need a wife.
他显然属于民主党内更务实的自由派。他很受欢迎。他是一个很好的组合。一旦他解决了健康问题，他显然会成为一线政治中的一员。但是多米尼克，一线政治家需要一个妻子，对吧？很好的观点，汤姆。很好的观点。他确实需要一个妻子。
And he is conscious of that. So in 1951, he'd met Jacqueline Bouvier at a Georgetown party. She is from an impecunious kind of stockbroker socialite family. Her parents had split up, and this had taken a great kind of psychological toll on her. She is a sort of shy but very sophisticated woman. She's 12 years his junior. I hadn't realized how big the age gap was. And actually, the marriage is not perfect. Well, to put it mildly. Yeah. He was cheating on her consistently up to their wedding day, and then after their wedding
他意识到了这一点。所以1951年，他在乔治城的聚会上遇到了杰奎琳·布维尔（Jacqueline Bouvier）。她来自一个贫困的股票经纪人社交名流家庭。她的父母分开了，这给她带来了巨大的心理创伤。她是一个害羞但非常世故的女人。她比他小12岁。我没意识到年龄差距有那么大。而且实际上，婚姻并不完美。嗯，说得委婉一点。是的。他在婚礼前一直持续地欺骗她，然后在他们的婚礼
day. And actually, I think if he were listening to this podcast, he would resent the use of those words because he doesn't really see it as cheating he thinks it's what a chap does because it's what his father had done openly yeah he's learned it from joe senior yes from joe senior and he clearly thinks you know a wife just has to put up with this just has to turn a blind eye to it but he said to his friends i'm both too young to get married and too old. And what he meant by that was, I'm too young. I want to have fun. I don't want to give up on my floundering ways. I like to go out and party. And too old, meaning I'm too set in my ways. I'm never going to change, not even for Jackie. And they bicker quite a lot. So does he marry her out of political expediency or is there a spark of love?
之后。而且实际上，我认为如果他在听这个播客，他会反感使用这些词，因为他并不真正认为这是欺骗，他认为这是一个男人该做的事，因为这是他父亲公开做过的事。是的，他从老乔那里学到的。是的，从老乔那里。而且他显然认为，你知道，妻子只需要忍受这一点，只需要对它视而不见。但他对朋友说，我结婚太年轻，也太老了。他的意思是，我太年轻了。我想玩得开心。我不想放弃我那风流的习惯。我喜欢出去聚会。太老了，意思是我的习惯已经定型了。我永远不会改变，即使是为了杰基。他们吵架吵得很厉害。那么他是出于政治权宜之计娶她，还是有爱情的火花？
No, I think he's definitely attracted to her. He likes the fact she's a Francophile. She's very sophisticated. Great taste in hats. Great taste in hats, exactly. She studied at the University of Grenoble and at Sorbonne. She spent time at Vogue in Paris. She's very cool. People have said of her that the Kennedys are obsessed with these touch football games on the kind of lawn outside their summer house. And she never joins in. She doesn't know the rules.
不，我认为他绝对被她吸引了。他喜欢她热爱法国文化的事实。她非常世故。帽子品味很好。帽子品味很好，没错。她在格勒诺布尔大学和索邦大学学习过。她在巴黎的《Vogue》待过一段时间。她很酷。人们曾评价她，肯尼迪家族沉迷于他们避暑别墅外草坪上的触式橄榄球比赛。而她从不参加。她不知道规则。
She doesn't join in. She stays a bit aloof. I so admire that. Well, you wouldn't join in, Tom, if I invited you around and insisted on you playing touch football? No, I'd sit there with my hat. Would you? Looking glamorous, sophisticated, and classy, Dominic.
她不参加。她保持着一点冷漠。我非常钦佩这一点。好吧，汤姆，如果我邀请你过来并坚持让你玩触式橄榄球，你也不会参加吧？不，我会戴着帽子坐在那里。你会吗？看起来迷人、世故、有格调，多米尼克。
Like the Jackie Kennedy of the rest is history. So yes, he's set fair. In 1956, he has a first brush with presidential politics because as this kind of young, handsome senator from Massachusetts, he is almost picked as the Democratic vice presidential nominee with Adlai Stevenson. And he actually really dodges a bullet there because Stevenson is just about to be steamrolled by Dwight D. Eisenhower, who's seeking re-election. And his vice president, Richard Nixon. And his vice president, Richard Nixon.
就像《历史的其余部分》里的杰基·肯尼迪一样。所以是的，他准备好了。1956年，他第一次接触总统政治，因为作为马萨诸塞州这位年轻、英俊的参议员，他差点被选为阿德莱·史蒂文森（Adlai Stevenson）的民主党副总统候选人。他实际上在那里躲过了一劫，因为史蒂文森即将被寻求连任的德怀特·D·艾森豪威尔（Dwight D. Eisenhower）碾压。还有他的副总统，理查德·尼克松。还有他的副总统，理查德·尼克松。
So if Kennedy had been on the ticket, he comes very close to being on the ticket. There's a big hullabaloo at the convention. They end up picking a name to conjure with Tom, Tennessee's Senator Estes Kefauver. They pick him instead of JFK. And had they picked JFK,k you know could he have come back in 1960 he could but he would have had one big loss you know on his record yeah as it is he's established himself as the kind of the great white hope as the glamour boy of the democratic party everyone has seen him on tv they've heard of him because of the war. They know he's got this glamorous wife, blah, blah, blah. He's got all this money. So actually, he looks like a nice
所以如果肯尼迪在竞选名单上，他非常接近进入名单。大会上有一场大骚动。他们最终选了一个名字，汤姆，田纳西州参议员埃斯蒂斯·基福弗（Estes Kefauver）。他们选了他而不是JFK。如果他们选了JFK，你知道他能在1960年卷土重来吗？他可以，但他记录上会有一次大失败，你知道的。是的，正如现在这样，他已经确立了自己作为民主党伟大的希望，作为民主党的魅力男孩。每个人都在电视上见过他，因为战争他们听说过他。他们知道他有一个迷人的妻子，等等。他有这么多钱。所以实际上，他看起来像是一个不错的
bet in 1960. He looks like a winner. He does look like a winner. So his dad would be proud of him. And his dad is still very much lurking in the background, isn't he? He's still around. Yeah, absolutely. So if his back can hold up, who knows? Could he get into the White House, Tom? Well, we'll find out, won't we? Will he transform America? We'll find out in the next episode. Well, do you know what? When I was reading Murder Mysteries as a boy, so I was addicted to Agatha Christie. I think we talked about this in Agatha Christie podcast. I would literally miss meals to find out what was going to happen in the mystery. And if you were of that disposition,
赌注，在1960年。他看起来像个赢家。他确实看起来像个赢家。所以他爸爸会为他感到骄傲。而且他爸爸仍然在幕后潜伏，不是吗？他还在。是的，绝对。所以如果他的背能撑住，谁知道呢？他能进入白宫吗，汤姆？好吧，我们会发现的，不是吗？他会改变美国吗？我们会在下一集发现。好吧，你知道吗？当我还是个男孩读谋杀悬疑小说时，我沉迷于阿加莎·克里斯蒂。我想我们在阿加莎·克里斯蒂的播客里谈过这个。我真的会错过吃饭时间来找出悬疑故事里会发生什么。如果你有那种倾向，
then all you have to do is to join the Restless History Club at restlesshistorypod.com. And you can find out what happens next. Right now, in fact, you can hear the whole solution to the mystery. Will JFK become president? Once he's become president, will anything unexpected happen? And if something unexpected does happen to him, why, who, what, where and when? So find it out now or if you don't want to you can wait but it'll be so much better yeah to listen to it all right now wouldn't it tom i
那么你所要做的就是加入restlesshistorypod.com的“历史的其余部分”俱乐部。你可以找出接下来会发生什么。事实上，现在你就可以听到这个谜题的全部解决方案。JFK会成为总统吗？一旦他成为总统，会发生什么意想不到的事情吗？如果他真的发生了什么意想不到的事情，为什么，谁，什么，哪里，什么时候？所以现在就去找出答案，或者如果你不想，你可以等，但这会好得多，是的，现在就听完，不是吗，汤姆？我
think it absolutely would so we've introduced the murdery and in our next episode we will look at how jfk becomes president and the course of that presidency and what happens before it is so brutally ended so we will see you very soon bye-bye bye and the course of that presidency and what happens before it is so brutally ended. So we will see you very soon. Bye-bye. Bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip
想绝对会。所以我们介绍了谋杀案，在下一集中，我们将看看JFK是如何成为总统的，以及那段总统任期的过程，以及在它如此残酷地结束之前发生了什么。所以我们很快就会再见。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持《其余的都是娱乐》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，
and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在我们的问答环节，我们揭开了娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。